but this is your rope belong we have  visual commencing approach naked squad  configuration of on three your that  clock's ticking time to hero  how many drops is that this week I  stopped counting at least we'll give it  by the Corps you think that's turbine  focus Europe one we are ready to confirm  loadout fury taking point with mounted  bellows I'll take the pulverizer gonna  crush some bugs  yeah it's slowed us all down  flamethrower just watch your anus  what about you turbine I'll take  traveler locked on the drop zone status  pilots  engines humming weapons hot  vice government turbine on the hide  let's grab some cords  you